Here, the solutions were 2 plus the square root of 10 or 2 minus the square
root of 10. Nice work if you got these two answers. So first, we add 6 to both
sides of our equation, so we can set up the left side to complete the square.
To complete the square, we're going to add b over 2 squared to both sides of
our equation. The b here is negative 4. So, b over 2 would be negative 2 and b
over 2 squared would be positive 4. Now, we're ready to write the left-hand
side as a perfect square. Since our b term is negative, we know we're going to
need x minus a number. It turns out it's x minus 2. Now you can either get that
by thinking about what binomial squared would give us this trinomial or you can
just pull it from this b over 2. This is negative 2, so we use that in our
binomial. Now that we have our perfect square, we take the square root of both
sides of the equation and we add two do both sides of our equation to solve for
x. And we know we can't simplify the swuare root of ten since there's not a
perfect square that divides into ten evenly